Jennifer will be going to her own
premiere very soon and she will be
joined by some other fabulous woman
Julia Roberts Kate Hudson they all star
in the new comedy Mother's Day and we
first hey you know no junk food for
breakfast Hank lets us he also lets you
go to school without any underwear Jen
is a single mom I'm here for a job Julia
an ambitious author do you have kids
career keeps me busy and Kate's sister
is gay and seems to be hiding it from
their mom just all this Mother's Day
stuff and I start thinking about how I
haven't talked to mom directed by Garry
Marshall who also did pretty woman we
noticed a few similarities first Julia's
wig reminded us of that blonde number
second Hector Elizondo is in the movie
he was the snooty hotel manager and then
there's Julia's laughs Kate sure seemed
to have a good time posting these pics
from the set as everybody's stories
intertwine I was adopted
I've always wondered did she just throw
me away what you have to do you have to
find your mother who should I make it
empty
hello Atlanta happy Mother's Day
now this is actually Julia's fourth
movie with Garry Marshall she also did
runaway bride Valentine's Day and of
course pretty woman